is five years ago I'm at Nordstrom's
that lady was in my life for five
minutes that impact is permanent you got
certain people that are one day certain
people that are a month certain people
that are a year certain people that are
a decade but if you think like if you
have a relationship with the man
upstairs and say how did this person
come into my life what is the chance of
me meeting this person or that what I'm
the luckiest man alive so when you look
at it from that perspective and then now
when I wake up in the morning at the
beginning you and I were you know joking
about poisoning the drink and I told you
I said if God takes me today man I've
lived the most incredible life I am so
grateful everything from here is Desert
and bonus and you know that's that's a
brief uh element of the story I haven't
told before
that's why I wanted to
ask for a show because your dedication
to success and and trying to replicate
that for other people I mean those days
when I was doing that I was broke I mean
broke I didn't have 50 bucks I was
borrowing change to get a cup of coffee
at Zabar's on the upper west side so I
could do a little stand up at night to
pray for the dream I had a buddy uh this
is totally true I had a buddy who worked
in food service for restaurants who
would drop off industrial sized cans of
tuna that I would survive on for weeks
most likely I'm gonna die mercury
poisoning you know but that thing like
that thing the struggle to the success
tell me I know I know your story but can
you give me like the brief like struggle
to success story yeah I mean you talk
about tuna you know when I was in the
Army I would get the tuna because it was
disgusting but the can was like 49 cents
at PX and you would mix it with mustard
because at least mustard would make it
tolerable and throughout the day I would
have three four five of these cans to
get the protein no listen tuna might be
the key to the whole operation I think
that's what it is well Mercury we're
both going to go through one day news is
going to come out Dave Rubin and Patrick
David are dealing with Mercury having
too much of it but no I mean look you
know it all starts with a dream I was
talking to a couple of the guys the
other day just yesterday we're doing a
zoom call with a couple of our
executives
and one of my guys says uh hey one of my
sales guys I'm dealing with he's very
difficult to deal with he's a pain in
the ass and he's tough to do this he's a
1099 guy not W-2 W2 you have the option
to Fire and coach and send them to
places but 10.99 you're working with
these guys right it's like you're
running a insurance office and real
estate office so he says what do I do
with him I said well let me tell you
what I do in these types of situations
I said for a guy like me I joined the
army at 18 okay April 15 1997 I get
shipped to uh Fort Jackson South
Carolina
um my ASVAB score wasn't high so I Only
Could Be infantry or mechanics so I
became a Hummer mechanic I had 13
Hummers to myself I had a couple fmtvs
and lmtvs these are the bigger trucks
and I had a hotel 8 certification which
means I can go tow cars out of the mud
you know trucks out of the mud and
that's what I did for a living I thought
I was going to do 20 years
literally I'm going to be in the Army
for 20 years then I'm going to get out
I'm going to get an additional 10 points
on my uh score to be working at the post
office or cop or firefighter because if
you're a former military you get that 10
points on the test so if somebody scores
75 but you're in the Army you get 85. if
you do 82 you do 92 right so I had that
advantage
then one day I get a call from a friend
of mine kogan he says hey Pat what are
you doing I said tomorrow I'm
re-enlisting for six years uh really
yeah I'm really listening tomorrow they
got me everything I want out of my
orders I'm going to go special forces
Delta Sears school you know I speak five
languages so they're gonna help me out
to sharpen my language and then I'm
going to go to Vicenza Italy which is
where I wanted to go to there was a
beautiful unit there and then from there
you know I'm gonna do this for 20 years
and I'm going to retire at 38 years old
and then I'm gonna go be a cop and
firefighter he says Pat you got to get
out I said I'm not getting out I'm
signing my contract tomorrow for six
years and I'm getting my Army
accommodation met I had gotten an Army
Achievement medal tomorrow was a
celebration Lieutenant Colonel peacocks
was going to give me an army
accommodation medal he says can I
convince you otherwise I said you can't
my dad already sent me a 250 camera as a
gift for committing to re-enlist he says
just give me an hour
and this guy was the only guy that ever
came and visited me in the Army out of
my friends for 18 days and when you're
in the Army you're alone you remember
all the letters I kept every letter
every single letter anybody ever wrote
me while I was on boot camp I have all
of it till today all of it you know like
who was a friend and who's thinking and
who's not all of them the people he
thought that your best they never wrote
you a letter the people you thought were
like they were okay they want you 50 60
letters
Trump's sitting there hour later it's
now one o'clock in the morning I got
formation early in the morning I can't
sleep all night I've already promised my
dad I'm on a realist he wants me to stay
in uniform be in the military I get out
in the morning go to Lieutenant Colonel
peacocks disappointing news for you I
can't re-enlist I got to get out but
David what are you doing we got you the
orders I said I totally under you you
have no clue how much I respect you but
I'm getting outside get out they don't
give me the Army accommodation medal how
difficult were those I mean I'm thinking
about it right now I'm going back
because I threw my boots over the you
know you you celebrate like hey this is
it it wasn't easy let me tell you it was
a lot of anxiety because when you're in
the military it's so regimented it's so
like routine and if you like routine
there's a lot of trust and comfort in
routine there's order there's
expectation there's a time for formation
it's a lot of good things your benefit
chow hall when you eat how much you get
paid your promotions correspondence
courses you got to take you know you'll
be an E5 E6 E7 eventually you'll be a
drill sergeant maybe you know first
sergeant that's our major E9 and that's
kind of the route you go and you can
take advantage of GI Bill maybe become
an officer or second Lieutenant first
lieutenant work your way up so there was
an immediate and you can travel see the
world it was you know 20 years what it's
going to look like it's predictable
and I like the predictable aspect but I
also have a uncertainty aspect the
unknown fires me up there's an element
of unknown that's exciting that the
level of curiosity I want to know what
the possibilities are
so then I get out I get out of the
military I come out to be a Hummer
mechanic and there was one shop at
Camarillo and it was Thousand Oaks
Camarillo that had a Hummer dealership
so I go and I said listen I'm the best
summer mechanic in Fort Campbell
Kentucky and the guy says listen man we
sell maybe one or two Hummers a month
each one we have one mechanic if we're
lucky we don't need a second one and I
say I'm very good at shooting he says
listen we don't need a Hitman here you
know you're not going to use it in
private
so at that point I want to took the test
to be a cop I had 16 speeding tickets so
I couldn't be a cop and then firefighter
there was a hold and then boom five year
freezing being a firefighter then I get
out and start making money in the
financial sector Morgan Stanley uh
Transamerica then I start my own
insurance company and the rest is
history the point I was making with this
meeting was the level of Grace God has
on us when you go back and think about
the people you met in your life some of
them were they made such a big impact in
your life but they're a five minute
person in your life you're at
Nordstrom's your son is wrestling with
you a woman over here who's 65 years old
looking at me for 10 minutes while me
and Dylan are wrestling I said ma'am how
you doing she's I'm doing good he said
do you know why I'm looking at you I
said why are you looking at me this is
because I remember when my kids were
that age
so tell me about your kids I have three
sons how are they doing what do they do
one's a doctor one's an engineer and
one's a lawyer really all successful all
successful all married with kids all
married with kids give me three Secret
Sauce what was it so I only give you one
I said what's that
she says if you ever threaten to
discipline your kids follow through
I was like out of all the advice you can
give you give me this if you threaten
them always follow through because your
word can't lose weight yeah this is five
years ago I'm at Nordstrom's that lady
was in my life for five minutes that
impact is permanent you got certain
people that are one day certain people
that are a month certain people that are
a year certain people that are a decade
but if you think like if you have a
relationship with the man upstairs and
say how did this person come into my
life what is the chance of me meeting
this person or that what I'm the
luckiest man alive so when you look at
it from that perspective and then now
when I wake up in the morning at the
beginning you and I were you know joking
about poisoning the drink and I told you
I said if God takes me today man I've
lived the most incredible life I am so
grateful everything from here is dessert
and bonus and you know that's that's a
brief uh uh element of the story I
haven't told before if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop screaming check out our
politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell